on l'appelle la zone rouge passer cette
porte tout est considérée contaminés
nous sommes dans l'unité réservé aux
itinérants montréal est atteint de la
coved 19 des patients comme andré
martelly qui vit dans un refuge et qui
n'auraient pas pu s'isoler deux semaines
mettez bien accueillir et bien aimé
l'ambiance plutôt par exemple le power
les changes et bien eu de la chance
l'homme atteint materi pris un bon petit
déjeuner que j'ai aimé marie-eve goyer
est à l'origine du projet mis sur pied
dans ce pavillon abandonné de l'ancien
hôpital royal victoria
notre objectif c'est vraiment d'être le
domicile pour des gens qui n'ont pas de
domicile
le personnel ici connaît bien les
itinérants pour plusieurs patients le
coronavirus s'ajoute une dépendance aux
opioïdes ou à l'alcool
on a cette expertise là on à la
médication qu'il faut on se retrouve à
être un espèce d'hybride entre le ch et
celle des avec des soins
peut-être un peu plus coriace mais sans
être nos guitares
ici pas de soins intensifs les cas plus
graves sont envoyés à l'hôpital jusqu'à
maintenant un itinérant est mordu
coronavirus à montréal mercredi ils
étaient six patients dans l'unité les
lieux pourront bientôt en accueillir une
centaine j'espère qu'on ne sera pas
utilisée dans les prochaines semaines
mais je le crains on a une clientèle
âgée avec plusieurs problèmes de santé
avec pas beaucoup d'accès aux ressources
et beaucoup de ressources qui sont
fermés
au centre-ville les cinq centres de jour
pour itinérants développer dans
l'urgence sont donc bien occupé ils
nourrissent 2000 personnes
quotidiennement s'attache à cash flow de
quelque chose à manger
alors ça aussi ça être sage musique on
peut manger et puis on remercie la ville
pour tous qui avait entre
comparativement à bien d'autres villes
je pense qu'on peut tiers de montréal
pour mieux respecter la règle des deux
mètres au moins 300 lits ont aussi été
fermés dans les refuges de montréal a
voté c'est la nuit aussi au problème
chinois alors la ville a rapidement dû
ouvrir de nouveau dortoir comme ici au
marché bonsecours montréal vient aussi
de réquisitionner deux hôtels un pour
les sans abri en attente de leurs
résultats au test du coronavirus l'autre
pour tous ceux qui se retrouvent à la
rue
on doit comme une petite armée la marche
et est rapidement ensemble et ouvrir le
plus de lits possible pour être capable
d'aider matin la bride et sécurisé c'est
solange ya pas beaucoup de codes
détecter encore sort pour ça pour nous
c'est vraiment gratifiant de dire parce
qu'on réussisse à les isoler le défi
restera énorme
montréal compte au moins 3000 itinérant
et la crise actuelle risque d'augmenter
leur nombre malades ou non
il leur faut garder le moral et rester
résilients parce qu'il ya toujours un
peu de soleil à l'heure du coronavirus
l'oms
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal